here's the article from marketwatch
wait till you hear this
six in ten
gen z investors
admit to trading while drunk
getting wasted and doing trades buying
the stock market buying doge i'm sure so
according to a survey from consumer
finance website magnify money
32 of u.s investors
admit to making trades while drunk
gen z
my young people out there in their early
20s they're leading the way with 59
confessing to drunk
trading you know they talk about don't
get a dui you might not want to get a
tui trading under the influence this is
the investing version of a dewey so why
are people
drunk trading i wanted a a laugh track
dude we gotta get it we gotta get them
that's on you david died a little bit
okay
david's wasted right now by the way i
don't know
so why are people drunk trading here's a
couple theories out there number one we
all got mobile phones we all got mobile
phones and that's definitely making
trading easier cool we get that all
right
so boom pull it up all right boom bing
bing bing bing bing we got the mobile
phone so that's easy to do that it's
obviously made
but why are young people more prone to
this i think it's 9 of baby boomers so
not a lot 32 of all u.s investors but
nearly 60 percent of gen z are like yo
bro i'm about to get wasted and make
some stock trades it's so easy to see
you saturday night homie
no all right well according to the
addiction center i mean they went full
on to the addiction center on this one
all right why they drink let's go i know
the experts according to the dixit
center they say that it's the because of
the gamification interface on trading
apps like
robinhood that could be a factor they
say and this is quote unquote from the
addiction center
the app simplicity and graphic design
make trading feel like gaming the
platform has drawn in young investors by
presenting complex financial instruments
like it's a fun
game let me repeat that they say the app
simplicity yeah and graphic design
make trading feel like you're playing a
game the platform has drawn in young
investors gen z
18 to 25
by presenting complex financial
instruments stock market options crypto
what have you like it's a good all fun
game yeah so that is a problem so here
you know technically you're not supposed
to give specific financial advice i get
it general financial advice
here's some financial advice out there
for the for the young folks out there
but anyways
you know how they say like alcohol makes
you emotional well that one buddy gets
wasted he's like i love you man i'm so
happy we're hanging bro i miss you bro
it's like buddy i saw you last week
relax bro you had one corona
you had a natty ice homie relax okay i
love you alcohol makes you emotional
think back to the decisions you've made
when you were hammered all right are
they the best decisions you've ever made
i don't think so we've all sent that i
got drunk i woke up with a mustache
we've all see we've all sent that 3m
text like you up yeah what's up now
exactly magnify that to your broker 3m
you up bro no dude sleeping
don't make a tui right now don't trade
under the influence so now imagine
you're getting drunk
and that stupid drunk text message that
you spent yeah now it's costing you
money it might cost you
you know a typical drunk text message
might cost you like a little dignity
yeah it caused my dignity right exactly
i can't believe i texted that girl for
him what the hell was i thinking my
ex-girlfriend bro oh my god
oh my god
but now imagine that drunk test actually
costs you
money that's not a good look so
if someone is trading drunk
here are some of the i never thought
that i would actually have to say these
words stop for a second don't trade
drunk
okay don't drive drunk
don't trade drunk
don't get drunk in vegas and marry
somebody and trade right after and trade
right after just don't do it
not worth it you're gonna look back and
be like oh my god i can't believe that i
traded i bought gamestop i bought 100
shares of gainstop i was wasted last
night game shop has plummeted uh 50
percent in the last two days oh [ __ ] oh
my god
so in all and with all kidding aside
it's actually absurd that 60 60 not 16
yeah 60
of gen z are getting wasted
right
and what are you doing tonight getting
drunk and making trades homies it's like
the nerdiest [ __ ] thing you're
hitting the club nah dawg
me
12 pack of corona light and robin hood
homie you me the boys rob the boys full
send
full send let's do it unbelievable so i
never thought i'd have to say these
words but don't trade drunk all right so
when it comes to investing in all
seriousness this is not something you
should be doing actively anyway active
trading making trades buy sell stop
timing the market i'm going to get in
i'm going to get out it's all about time
in the market let it marinate not trying
to time the market you should be
investing for the long
term so if you want you know investing
should be boring i say this all the time
investing should be boring long term
investing buy and hold you want
excitement hit the club bro don't hit
robin hood yeah right delete robin hood
exactly you want you want excitement i
just came back from vegas hit the casino
cool you got a 500 budget if i lose it
all good if i win it double it amazing
if you want to get excited about
something
don't get excited about investing get
excited about your career
get excited about what you want to do in
life get excited about your prospects
get excited about networking get excited
about things that are tangible get
excited about
seeing your friends
don't get excited about a robin hood app
at four in the morning schwasted okay i
i never thought i'd have to say that so
with that being said no more 2am drum
text
no more duis
no more tuis trading under the influence
makes sense
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken